SO CNNKEEPERS MAY HAVE BEE
JANUARY 6th IN  AN INTERVHITE
HOUS AST STARTEDO BE LEFT OUT O
DEVELOPMENN NUh
INVESTIGIO
US
NG FOR
O,NI
MIC
MICHAE
LL DA'SISTANT.
NEWS ABOUT HU, ON TH
ARITI
THK TOENAT
HAS T DOWN
WHAT CERTAIN OFFICIALS A
ICS CNS IN ITS D-NEW REPORT WELO
PROSECUTOR?
>> WELL, I
US THEAT THE PRIDINTENT
TRUMP COT WI LESTHEN THAT WOULD
OR
INNTOSR IN
AN ORDERLY FASHION.TELY CORRECT
IN
OPTIONS FOHOW WORRIEARE THEY?RS
IGIOTHEY'RMI
PUZZLER WAYS TTHE IMPORTANT INHH
UT
HAN YI
THE TALKS  AIDESAL OFFICE AT TH
THEYAVR WAYS TO TOGE T NARRATIV
THAT.
NICHOLAS, THE COMMITTEE,SO
JARED R
THIS WEEK, THE
SON-AWAN
HOW DO C
PIECES HERE, OR ISIFE MORE
OM.N ARETTY GU
HE'S PROBABLY ONE
IN THENN CIRTO
INTEIE FAR.BU REMHETH OF THP TOB
OVERTURNTH
AN
THRY,  PT OFAT
HAPPENED HERE, NOTT
JANUARY 6tP T,HE
AN CAN H FRAUD CONSPIE
TEIVE. SEEMSACERY.
IT WASN'T A TOTAL
HE WOULD SHO
BUT HA TAT SEEITN , THE FACTO TT
THING  COMMITTEE
CE  TOWARD
.MONY OF
>> YOU'VE E DE
INVESTIGATIO A
PTU EXPAN H
TO LISSOIT Y
THIS, AND THEN IAL.
Y PRRE FRE PROSECTOEA
LAW, >>T FEEL PRESSURE.WE NTHAO
IT.HOT SUCCUMB INNY
URE OF
POLITICIANS FOR HI
LENS H L PEOPLE WHERTURE
THE RALLIES ANTH A
BROADEN
ABT  AND THES
REMEMBER,
IS TO BEE TO PROVE BREASONDENC
FO NOT A POL E
LIRE THECA